[Music]
you have no interest in what I have to
say unless it confirms what you think
you will really know my job was simple
[Music]
save the country I loved from being
destroyed as your job any different I
have a lead on the great enemy of our
people Adolf Eichmann the architect of
the final solution
the trail went cold in 46 latest
intelligence suggests one who situs this
guy convinced rabbis to load the trains
themselves and not by force if it is him
we need an elite crew I'm not joining
your head squad I would happily put a
bullet in between his eyes but that's
not what we're doing here this is
strictly catching extract
- we'll stand trial here in Israel think
what it means
finally publicly holding to account the
man who organized our slaughter
[Music]
our memory reaches max who recorded
history the book of memory is still a
nice open
and you hear now other hand that holds
the pen
[Music]
if you succeed
for the first time in our history
we will judge executioner
and we will warn off any who may wish to
follow his example
if you fail
he escapes justice
perhaps forever
[Music]
I beg you do not fail
[Music]
you